uh here's something really interesting
this is sort of related to the marjorie
taylor green twitter and facebook ban
um about
what was it like a month ago three weeks
ago something like that i played a video
clip for you of republican congressman
dan crenshaw who is a trump guy
there's no doubt about it dan crenshaw's
a trump guy
criticizing the so-called freedom caucus
of the house of representatives which is
a very trumpy caucus saying these people
are performance artists and they are not
at the end of it of the day really the
people that voted in support of what
donald trump wanted
this conflict between crenshaw and
people like marjorie taylor greene
is now like two trains barreling towards
each other because after this ban stunt
from marjorie taylor green by stunt i
mean how she reacted to it
uh dan crenshaw
has much more directly attacked her and
marjorie taylor green has now turned on
him so let me kind of explain it all to
you
in the immediate hold let me get this
all looking correct here in the
immediate aftermath of her being banned
dan crenshaw posted
that marjorie scoffed at the notion of
supporting anti-censorship legislation
is indicative of her true intent to
remain a victim she doesn't want
solutions and she doesn't care if you
get censored she just wants to be a
victim so she can keep asking you for
campaign donations it's a scam
dan crenshaw is 110 correct here he's
110 correct now understand
that what he was advocating for was
seriously heavy regulation of platforms
like twitter and facebook so he is a
hypocrite in the sense that he is part
of the party that says we should do as
little regulation of business as
possible
uh
regulating businesses socialism he's
talked on the joe rogan show about his
belief about what socialism is and it's
a very very wrong belief so he was
ignoring his so supposedly sincerely
held beliefs about a light government
regulatory touch saying let's regulate
these companies but he is correctly
pointing out
that marjorie taylor green had the
opportunity to support anti-censorship
as they call it legislation and that
what she is doing is a scam to raise
campaign contributions he's completely
right
he also posted i think this is on his
instagram hey by the way marjorie isn't
this you
this was the moment you went for a few
drinks instead of voting on the ndaa
before bringing up miss votes you might
want to check your own record this is
after marjorie taylor green said to dan
crenshaw hey you've missed votes as well
this is a picture of marjorie taylor
green
sitting at a bar when apparently voting
was taking place on ndaa the substance
of this matters less than the fact that
two pro-trump republicans that's what
they are
are fighting with each other
crenshaw went on to say hey marjorie if
suggesting we should paul follow trump
policy instead of biden mandates makes
you mad then you might be a democrat or
just an idiot so
very big attacks trump on trump violence
crenshaw then posted guess some people
woke up today and tried to compete for
biggest idiot on the internet
then going on to say
seeing a lot of manufactured outrage by
some people lately they're worried
they're losing their grip on your
attention because they are
they lash out in the hopes you'll pay
attention to them kind of sad really
dan crenshaw is totally right here about
what marjorie taylor green is doing
these are what we call what i call asbs
attention seeking behaviors and crenshaw
went on to say and marjorie
instead of playing the victim about
censorship
maybe use your position as a legislator
to help pass legislation against
censorship luckily i've already done all
the hard work for you and drafted a bill
that would change section 230 to
prohibit political censorship wannaco
co-sponsor before i introduce it or do
you prefer to keep up with petty and
childish attacks
your call
marjorie taylor green
completely then losing it on dan
crenshaw
saying dan crenshaw is posting creepy
stalking pictures of me referring to the
picture from the bar
and harassing me
to co-sponsor his big tech bill that he
says stop censorship but his bill
actually gives more protection to online
porn companies very very weird thing to
post
and then lastly she wrote
no thanks dan we need to get rid of porn
i am busy reading other republican stop
big tech censorship bills gosh and to
think all of this started when i just
disagreed with him when he said fema
should be doing mass coveted testing and
working in hospitals all i said is no
we don't want fema doing any of that and
hospitals need to hire back unvaccinated
healthcare workers then poof i'm kicked
off twitter did i offend dan's globalist
friends at the world economic forum
um this is this is really great i have
to tell you guys i wish that the left
was was more competently preparing for
uh 2022 and 2024 uh i think the left may
be heading for a disaster
but
trump is fighting with trumpists is a
really really good thing and just to
remind everybody here's that original
clip where dan crenshaw seemed to start
expressing some disdain for the grifters
like marjorie taylor green and others
without naming them directly remember
this supporting these two
there's actually other veterans in
morgan's race
there's other front runners but why
support these two well because i've been
in congress for almost three years now
there's two types of members in congress
right there's performance artists
there's legislators
now the performance artists are the ones
that get all the attention
but the ones you think are more
conservative because they know how to
say slogans real well
they know how to recite the lines that
they know that our voters want to hear
let me tell you guys something in the
first two years of trump's presidency
when republicans were in control when
every single time we were voting on
donald trump's agenda
what do you think was at the top of that
list voting with trump and who do you
think was at the bottom yeah
a lot of names you would recognize are
at the bottom of that list a lot of
things you would recognize are at the
top of that list
number two it's probably going to make
you cringe a little bit it's adam
kensinger
voted with trump almost 99
he was number two
so the important thing the important
takeaway here
is that
these are all trumpists in some sense
marjorie tate marjorie taylor green is a
trumpist in the way that she has
completely abandoned even talking about
policy
spreads lies disinformation it's kind of
like the cartoonish weaponized trumpist
but what dan crenshaw reminds us
is that a lot of the people that we on
the left might say they're not that bad
liz cheney wow she said biden really won
that's that's really great adam
kinzinger hey he was willing to vote to
convict trump on impeachment
uh i'm sorry
to uh he was willing to support
impeachment of donald trump uh he's a
member of the house not the senate uh
and we say wow these people are kind of
more reasonable
they vote with trump all the time all
the time and so they are not our
political allies dan crenshaw's
absolutely right let's hope that this
trump on trump civil war continues
because the left needs something to help
us along this year
one of our sponsors is splendid spoon
now if you're like me i love planning my
meals out for the week but sometimes i
just run out of time to plan them for
every single day and splendid spoon
makes that whole process a lot easier
they deliver fresh delicious plant-based
meals right to your door ready to eat no
cooking no cleaning dishes saves you a
lot of time you can choose from over 50
hot and cold meal options there's
smoothies grain and noodle bowls soups
i'm a big soup guy many of you know that
i also really liked the vegan meatballs
with marinara noodles delicious
both i and splendid spoon believe
eating more plant-based is a great tool
for feeling good
for helping the environment the list
goes on i'm not vegan you all know that
i think but splendid spoon is really
great to just help me maximize the
proportion of plants in my diet splendid
spoon takes all of the work out of tasty
healthy plant-based meals and you'll
save 35 dollars when you go to splendid
splendidspoon.com
pacman the link is down below